bonjour d'abord je voudrais vous
féliciter pour votre nomination au par
le gouvernement et pour chacun d'entre
vous ce sera dans sa vie à la fois un
événement est une responsabilité une
épreuve et je vous souhaite de réussir
c'est l'intérêt non pas seulement de
vous mais de l'ensemble du pays le
gouvernement précédent a fait beaucoup
pour poursuivre le développement
premièrement les conditions
macroéconomiques ont été instaurées et
ça c'est très important
et bien évidemment sans cela il n'y
aurait aucun résultat après tout ce qui
a été obtenu grâce à un travail
important et doit être exploitée pour
l'avenir
pour parvenir au résultat d'intérêt
national et utiliser les instruments
qu'ils étaient construits qui ont été
mises en place notamment pour les grands
projets donc le précédent gouvernement à
travailler là dessus il a mis en place
des instruments qui sont utiles et cela
encore une fois va dans l'intérêt du
pays et la priorité c'est bien
évidemment du d'améliorer le bien-être
de la population et tout cela ce sont
des objectifs qui sont tout à fait
réalistes
encore une fois je vous souhaite bonne
chance et je suis convaincu que vous
ferez tout votre possible pour que nous
puissions parvenir aux objectifs qui ont
été fixés
chez un membre du gouvernement
tout d'abord je voudrais encore une fois
vos salué pour la confiance ce qui a été
établi et vous savez nous savons tous
que la responsabilité qui nous incombe
est très importante et nous allons
aujourd'hui mener la première réunion
gouvernementale
nous allons étudier la location
l'allocution du président mais aussi
d'autres objectifs qui ont été fixés le
gouvernement est très équilibré il ya un
certain nombre de personnes qui ont
travaillé dans le gouvernement précédent
mais il ya aussi un fort taux de
renouvellement et en se servant de cela
nous pourrons obtenir les meilleurs
résultats et monsieur mais justin je
vous suis je vous souhaite succès dans
vos travaux
au revoir